hi we are part of the Natural Area
volunteers group and this is our team so
what are we're a group of seven what we
all have in common is either a
concentration or a major and sustainable
development and our project managers are
Tala and Chris so the purpose of the
capstone workshop is that it centers
around the client so it helps us to
integrate the curriculum that we've been
learning in our classes for these three
or four years and apply it towards a
problem to help solve with the client
not for the client but kind of in
conjunction with the client and through
this whole process we have to serve as
consultants and really understand the
constraints that these types of
organizations face before offering our
objective solution so our client is the
natural areas volunteer program which is
a subset that's managed by the NYC Parks
Department um they the goal is to help
establish in New York City as a primary
destination for volunteerism that's
environmentally focused and the mission
of nav is to restore and protect these
natural areas within New York City
through volunteerism and training and
this mission includes identifying
invasive species removing the invasive
species but also just general
restoration techniques now the mission
of nav is not currently being fully met
because there's a problem with
recruitment and retention for example in
2012 they had 117 stewards that were
volunteering with the program and nav
has a recommended 12 hours of volunteer
for volunteers hours per person but
actually out of those 117 people only 14
people completed those 12 hours and only
40 people completed two hours which
means that everybody else did less than
two hours of volunteer
so there's a limited recruitment
strategy limited implementation
practices unlimited expansion goals and
also they really highlighted a minimal
lack of minimal engagement from locals
around the parks and they really wanted
to have us focus on the people who live
in the areas where they're focusing on
for retention and they have minimal
retention of long-term dedicated
volunteers mainly because they have an
unfocused volunteer management system
and that probably stems from their lack
of communication structures both
internally and externally within the
program so on our first meeting with our
client we were handed a survey that was
done in June of 2012 with a sample size
of 69 people and one of the things that
was on there was the demographics of the
current volunteers as you can see
students take up about thirty-five
percent of the demographics followed by
the other employment sectors and we
focused on these three just because we
saw potential with organizations as well
as students so students we saw an
opportunity to capitalize on just the
willingness to be engaged in hands on
group project work for organizations nav
really wanted to focus on connecting
corporations with maybe one time work
days but also we wanted to incorporate
their vision to include more engagement
from locals surrounding the parks
another thing found in that original
survey was how people heard about the
program and this is where we saw our
biggest problem because as you can see
email mailing list is the highest and
rightfully so because that's what their
strategy was beforehand in social media
is at the lowest end of the spectrum and
that's because it's not a focus or
priority right now we saw this is a
problem because social media has many
advantages so minimal costs the
communication possibilities are endless
which would really help to address those
communication problems that we
identified in our problems and also it's
a platform that many age groups can use
dates can use daily it's not just a
platform for students anymore a lot of
people are now using it so we're going
to expand the social media spearhead an
advertising campaign solidify the
branding of the product of the project
we create a new logo we did a bunch of
stuff that will tell you about and just
encourage outreach from volunteers to
potential volunteers so to begin
addressing these problems we just
decided to do some background research
some case studies we have 11 of them
listed in our final report but we just
detailed two of them here each one of
them has a summary with an analysis and
key takeaways for each one the first one
was with a nonprofit called volunteer
for Long Island and this is actually a
really recent case study um it was right
after Hurricane sandy they were looking
to put together packages for individuals
who were affected by the hurricane for
thanksgiving day and the problem is what
they didn't have enough volunteers which
is very similar to the nav program so
they launched a twitter account even
though they already had a facebook page
and a YouTube video from another
volunteer an issue they did back in two
thousand eight and then they use this
website is called we follow calm and
their uses as a tool to find other
people with similar interests what they
ended up doing is they found this group
of people called the Long Island tweetup
which basically is a group that meets
finds need within their community and
goes and helps out as a group so through
this website volunteer for Long Island
was able to find the Long Island tweetup
and they were able to directly message
them with tweets about the event so they
found that people began retweeting the
tweets and then this drove more traffic
to the Facebook page there were more
fans on Facebook within hours and
they've received messages from potential
volunteers and they were able to
ultimately reach
our target off volunteers so through
this website we saw as an opportunity
for a takeaway to be used as a tool to
reach other people with similar
interests our second case say that we're
going to talk about here is in the
oakland city parks but there was a
supervisor who was originally just
responsible for one rose garden but
because of budget cuts she found herself
responsible for an additional 12 sites
and this clearly became a management
problem so what she did was she created
her own website so that people could log
their own volunteer hours so she would
no longer be in charge of that aspect of
it so she can focus her time on other
things and she logged it she had people
log in a very transparent way which
actually fostered competition within the
volunteers to try to outdo each other
with volunteer hours and she used this
in combination with the rest of her
existing social media presence and the
results were amazing she found that she
was able to raise more money just by
showing different organizations the City
Council that people were interested in
actually volunteering their time also
people responded well to the social
media and actually met met her at the
parks where she said that she would be
on Facebook or on Twitter things like
that now because of this website she's
able to run over a hundred different
sites and this website is actually
available nationwide for free so our key
takeaway is maybe enemy can use this
website it's a very easy creation of an
account and it might be able to address
some of the problems that anybody has so
next we started to go into our strategy
overview and deliverables so we broke it
up into the same categories that we
divided the problem into so recruitment
and retention for recruitment we created
a marketing internship program we also
created step-by-step guides for facebook
twitter instagram and linkedin now the
reason why we didn't create actual
accounts was because we had meetings
with the media and IT department within
the parks department and it was found
that they didn't want to separate the
NYC Parks from the nav program just yet
but there was some promise for the
potential for this decision to be taken
away in the future so we created just
these step-by-step guides just to give
the program managers some idea of
familiarity with these tools how to use
them how to create them and just guides
for how to manage the pages once they're
up and running and next we created a
promotional video and we provided a list
of potential partners where they can
either draw volunteer activity from or
just partner with future events and
lastly we create a volunteer survey just
to get another feel for their current
volunteers so for the marketing
internship program we drafted a notice
that will be advertised in either
lyonshare or through the sustainable
development internship emails and it's
just a 15 hour per week internship that
manages the social media presence when
and if that ever occurs but just
generally beyond that connecting
corporate groups and the community
partners to volunteer days and to just
distribute regular marketing material so
our step-by-step guide for facebook is
personalized to the needs of nav and the
NYC parks but ultimately we have this
vision to create a place where
volunteers can post questions comments
interact with program staff get
information about training and planting
and all of these things are included in
our deliverable which is the
step-by-step guide and we just did a
little snippet of what it looks like
this is a screenshot of our actual
step-by-step guide in our appendix but
we've made it very clear of how to add
content to a Facebook page how to create
a Facebook page when to create posts how
to do this and what it looks like at the
end we did the same thing for Twitter so
we explained that Twitter is a different
space with kind of a different purpose
but it's all part of the same social
media presence where volunteers can
connect to
program initiatives stay engaged with
maybe random facts or receive news on
work days or where people are going to
be and actually in our step-by-step
guide for Twitter we have custom
hashtags just so that enemy can begin to
control the conversations that people
are having with them on social media
this is just another like example
snippet from our step-by-step guide now
Instagram we see as a completely awesome
opportunity to put it lightly just
because it'll help to create a visual
represented representation of the
program which we feel is really
important because we want people to be
able to come to a place where they can
just easily see what it looks like to be
a volunteer in the nav program so we
have ideas in our step-by-step guide for
photo ops for weekly photo contests for
just putting up photos every once in a
while of people doing different things
with the nav program so this could be a
really cool part of their social media
presence this is just again another
snapshot of how we walk them through
step by step and the guide same deal
with linkedin linkedin is more geared
towards organizations and professional
pages so we saw this is a way to target
the organizations in the one-time work
days that they really wanted to focus on
and so once again we created a guide for
them so we also wanted to create a new
logo this slide doesn't do it justice
because you don't see the before and
then after but it's pretty cool so as
you can see we keep the same color
scheme or relatively the same color
scheme we wanted to have our new logo
resemble the parks logo just because we
felt it was important to convey the
connection between the two at the same
time we really wanted to create a clean
fresh nav rebranding so this is our
proposed new logo and we can't wait to
hear our feedback from our client on
Wednesday
so for our promotional video we actually
have the promotional video but because
of speakers the situation it's hard to
play it so I'll just tell you about it
it has an inspiring program overview we
really wanted to convey the importance
and motivate people to want to volunteer
as well as just tell them what the
program is inform them how they can get
involved in order to get the footage for
it we attended a volunteer site we
filmed staff during the work day we got
some advice from people we heard
people's opinions and then where this
video will actually eventually be
integrated with a new social media
presence this was just an example of a
promotional video that we looked at for
inspiration for our own inspiration and
it was done by the British Columbia
parks what we kept the same was the fact
that they've really conveyed a message
of not only helping with the parks
department but how the parks department
and volunteering with them actually
helped them to fulfill their own goals
so we tried to convey that's that same
message in our video but ours is
definitely shorter this one's about four
and a half minutes and ours we wanted to
keep very succinct and organized so ours
is only a minute and a half for our
volunteer survey so we created this
survey we wanted to assess volunteer
satisfaction and support so we sent it
to nav volunteers it was sent out to 44
people on November 29th and then we
analyzed their responses it was broken
into all the categories that we felt
would be beneficial for nav to get some
more information on umm staff the level
of recognition that people are getting
communication support all these
categories and although our sample size
is small we only had eight respondents
we were able to notice some very clear
Chen's just from the beginning so one of
the trends was in recruitment so people
thought that they could recruit friends
that's this big chunk but this big chunk
says that they have not already sorry so
we just saw this as an opportunity to
capitalize on this imbalance basically
um so we we thought that it would be
helpful for anybody to know that they
can provide tools for grassroots
recruitment people are willing to
recruit just on their own terms so if
they're provided the right tools we see
that this is a very low cost way of
increasing retention for commitment a
lot of people as you can see from these
graphs felt that they could almost
commit more time and that they want to
be more active in that nav program now
granted the people who are answering
this survey are probably self selected
for the most dedicated volunteers but
still if the most dedicated volunteers
want to commit more time maybe nav
should focus more energy on giving
opportunities for these people for more
time instead of just focusing on the
people who aren't who don't want to be
involved who don't really want to give
that time another deliverable we
presented was just a list of
partnerships now these organizations are
just a few of the ones that we focused
on in our final deliverable section in
our final report we have the names the
descriptions and contact information so
that they can link up with these
partnerships in the future but also we
just came up with a but through research
we came up with a bunch of NGOs and
little organizations in and around the
specific parts of focus and so these are
also included in that contact
information and that lives at the end so
that basically concludes our whole
deliverable section but we just wanted
to emphasize what this taught us about
sustainable development just going
through this process so number one the
connection between parks and sustainable
development parks creating awareness or
connection to our environment
and volunteerism is the first step
towards developing sustainable practices
and habits if you're more connected with
the environment but also we ran into a
lot of roadblocks along the way we had
the media and IT department shut us down
we had a lot of brainstorming ideas that
we thought were really cool that maybe
wouldn't work and practice for a number
of different reasons and what we had to
do is we had to come together afterwards
work around those roadblocks and
actually come to a solution that would
work for everybody so we thought that
this was really relevant to our studies
in sustainable development so um
assuming that a next team is selected
for the same project next semester and
we see them organizing some sort of an
organizational work day with Columbia
students so their clubs here that are
already focused on volunteering and
connecting with the community and we
think that we can dig into those people
but also just to invest more time in
working with the New York City IT
department within the parks we really
feel and still do feel that immediate a
social media presence separate from
parks would be so beneficial to this
program and we actually provided some
materials in our final report for how to
fight against this internal bureaucracy
that prevents them from doing so but
also just like as a final recommendation
just maybe to focus a little bit more on
face-to-face recruiting just because
this is such a personable um volunteer
activity that maybe instead of social
media might not be the only option and
it might not be the end-all be-all but
if you combine this with like actual
relationships and face-to-face
recruitment we see this program going
really far are there any question what
was the goal for recruitment
when you began the project you talked
about how many volunteers they had but I
what was then right they actually hadn't
set any future goals for for recruiting
numbers you know they kind of were not
actively recruiting either they had a
small presence on the parks department
website with their contact information
but no outreach at all aside from that
other questions did you think about or
including your report what a social
media strategy like if you're not able
to separate out nav from the new york
city parks I mean it's I feel like
social media is kind of its they could
do it I guess on their own terms as in
the comp navigator for the Stewart to
kind of they themselves could create
their own Facebook events or
conversations but that's kind of up to
up to that as stewards so I guess it'd
be a suggestion that we need to give
them but I thought they are they they
aren't you well versed and social media
so I think it's even difficult for them
to have that conversation so we kind of
try to give them models or suggestions
for what there's would look like and I
guess we could
come to them about how to go about doing
that as well what we really tried to do
was kind of demystify social media for
this group they really weren't like my
dishes saying they weren't well-versed
in how to create it how to use it how to
take advantage of it so part of this
process was also just trying to teach
what it could do for them so that they
could also utilize the new york city
parks page if they wanted to we have a
lot of volunteers who you said were sort
of doing less than two hours on a
regular basis of disgrace was there any
any capacity to reach out those people
find out why why they does you know was
it just that they hadn't been asked to
victim or what well which we try to we
went to a work day sigh and there were
um no volunteers there which just kind
of highlights the problem we also had
the survey sent out to everybody in like
I said we only received less than
twenty-five percent of our sponsoring so
we it's almost as if we tried all the
avenues that we had access to um but
it's definitely recommended to address
those questions and they were addressed
in our survey but like I said they were
probably stuff self-selecting than that
survey we did asked in the survey how
many hours but how many hours each
volunteer had had contributed in the
past year and if we kind of got a spread
from the the responses that we got you
know all of them had completed two hours
all of the respondents only one of them
had completed more than six I think so
it was kind of a spread of all the
different types of volunteers
all all eight of the volunteers though
answered that they understood that 12
hours was recommended what we had
alluded to earlier in the presentation
was the fact that their communication
system internally is pretty disorganized
blog so part of our report is addressing
those issues and it's also part of the
internship program hoping that in turn
might be able to revitalize this
communication system and hopefully that
will remedy the volunteerism issues as
well